my girlfriend showed me a tick tock
video on how to let your
curly hair naturally fall
and it turned out like this you look
sexy it's good
i look like hagrid trying to get a
makeover you look halfway to chris
cornell my friend you'll be there soon
enough
time to shave the head again it's going
to take some time before my head
goes i think i know what you're doing
when i changed the part in my hair oh
that was an ordeal we got
a lot of uh comments coming in randomly
recently off of the one caleb sitter
reaction we did
a long time ago so i was like you know
what everyone's right
by everyone i mean like 10 people are
right
10 out of 10 people agree we should do
this one
when the hero is just as smart as
villain let's see what it's all about
so you're the legendary thief that
everybody's tried so hard to catch
who's asking the wonder question okay
first off why do y'all do that
who's asking what do you expect me to
say to that you you're just giving
yourself away
and i and what do i say
stupid like at least try to like act
like you don't know english or something
you're more creative like
sorry i don't i don't speak with you
nevermind
i'm the guy that's gonna catch you oh
really with whatever it is oh there's
plenty of evidence
like what's in the hoodie pocket what
this bottle why would a simple water
bottle incriminate okay
you're smarter than you look the line
doesn't work
but anyways i have reason to believe
that you tried
to steal a key to a safe that held
millions upon millions of dollars
however i swapped that key
with a banana before you
[Music]
but i only expected that
yes really i expected you to swap that
out
with this banana so i managed to steal
the key before i stole it
and implanted it that you would swap it
with
the
so that when you inevitably swap the
real one with the fake one you naturally
put the real one back in its place
in other words the one in that banana is
the fake one
this is like death note but i thought
ahead
i planted bombs around the city that i
could detonate at
several locations if you don't give me
the key
right now what will it be
the key or destruction
it's a hard decision it's a good thing i
don't have to pick
because this is the battery to your debt
i'd be angry but i didn't already put
the bombs on a backup timer
i'd be pressed if we didn't already
disarm
i'd be upset if i didn't
you might want to answer that
hello yeah i'm calling back this number
uh because you're dragging them
[Laughter]
like everyone else that sucks
because we relocated those bombs to your
dry cleaners
[Music]
i think you missed one beat
[Laughter]
bro i'm not even here what
talking to me i've been chilling
i was chill good luck good luck trying
to find me
feel alive wait what i need luck for
i'm in your it
[Music]
that's not true
[Music]
how did you find me you're
welcome dope you are welcome caleb city
oh that's pretty freaking creative man
from my understanding caleb city is a
big anime fan
and this really seems like something out
of it i was thinking of like l
in death note oh yeah this totally
reminded me of just
of a parody of death basically i
wouldn't be surprised that's where the
main inspiration was coming from but i
love this concept because it's like the
title when the hero is just as smart as
the villain and i love that it's turned
into this game of just ridiculous tops
yeah one up one another the entire time
to the point where it's just
insanely absurd and completely
unrealistic
around every corner of it because i
thought it was just gonna turn into a
session like when it starts off i
thought it was going to turn into he's
going to be just pointing out and making
fun of how dumb the villain is
with the initial setup of the beat but i
love where it really went into of how it
just kept
escalating into oh he's out just keep
outsmarting each other till the very end
oh yeah with the biggest tropes ever the
key the bombs in the city
the disarming the backups yeah
every single trope was covered that was
so smart so brilliant
yeah and then to take it fully off-road
and go with the whole lag i've been
chilling
this whole time in my room facing to
like totally break the reality like it's
awesome too because yeah at the
beginning of the sketch it catches you
off guard the same way it would in a
movie or a show like that where oh
it looks like the villain's about to be
had and then of course you know then
they get into the game of insurmountable
talks
yeah yeah just the way he played it too
and there's some things that's so
charming about the
the diyness of the whole video
just yeah how it's perfectly cinematic
but also perfectly lo-fi enough to
really just fully suit the tone of
everything well yeah it's like uh
it reminds you of like when you're a kid
and making these home videos and if
he's doing it all by himself right the
idea that he's doing these
editing tricks yeah that are not all
that
fancy but he's trying to sell it in a
way
the whole joke is that he's overselling
it yeah exactly
and with the whole thing with the sound
and the delay
and that was stuff that made me think of
anime in a subconscious kind of yeah of
course especially that upside down shot
because of course when someone's
monologuing to keep things
interesting we have to throw in like a
crazy angle or something like that
and death note again and i'm sure many
other anime are full of that who
succeeds beyond anime this is like so
there's so many villain tropes that he's
covering here this is like comic books
and
uh all kinds of tv shows i've seen any
any of anything with like investigative
trying to take down the villain type of
tale
yeah detective versus master criminal
yeah i would love to know how he comes
up with all this
i don't know where it stems from like
where these bits come from on certain
like physical gags like with the banana
and the water bottle yeah was he just
messing around one day and
just wanted to carry a banana around and
put it in this water bottle that he
happened to have or
did he come up with this bit and then
had to go searching for a water bottle
that would fit a banana or did he just
have
those appliances in his home like these
are the weirdest things i think about
when i watch one of these sketches
how do they come up with this bit where
did this bit originate from
yeah exactly like that's the thing is
for some of these even for the simplest
of things i start to get fascinated by
what was the process behind this
yeah like did you write this whole thing
out first and get a good idea of what
you wanted or did you just do a bunch of
takes and then
tear it down from there i'd imagine that
he'd have and i i don't know the style
but i imagine for the fact that he's
doing it all by himself
i only did one video this in this whole
channel
time where i'm playing off of just me
and then that disney buys the right to
the bible video and that's hard
because you got to really map out the
reactions and everything
to yourself so this has two of yourself
yeah people
so you have to scr i feel like you have
to script it out unless he's just
an amazing just like the best editor in
the world to work
so used to unless the editing is just so
underrated here
that editing does get overlooked often
like things like him
or uh long beach griffey or like even
ryan george's
pitch meetings and such that editing
generally is overlooked however
he could just be so amazing that he just
does a bunch of improv and then commits
as much to memory of what he did as the
other guy
yeah yeah it just goes to the editing
session and has like
like an hour of footage yeah he makes it
down to four minutes
yeah i've been really enjoying getting
back into this kind of youtube comedy
because it reminds you of the beauty of
the fact that yeah like
like there are a few channels and you
brought yeah long beach griffey and ryan
george and screen rant stuff that are
yes so there's you can make these really
fun really inventive little sketches
just talking to yourself
yeah all you need is maybe a green
screen and a little bit of editing
prowess with the sounds and whatnot well
him and long beach griffie are great at
this because they just do them all for
phones or they're
like mobile cameras you know yeah it's
like the angles don't get
very shiny part of the charm is that you
know they're holding the camera
yeah and they're just at home or
wherever because it lets you in on the
the self-awareness that much more
because you know they're telling the
jokes to the audience
and it heightens the whimsy because
we're all agree that's the suspension of
disbelief is to go oh yeah they're not
in his house
all right guys well what did you think
of this video i mean this is i think
this might be his most popular video
he's ever had on his channel
superhero interviews oh geez super human
in her super human sorry
how did you ever do well on the movies
caleb city
subscribe to caleb city if you haven't
done so already you'll be doing yourself
a favor subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell get
notified whenever i got a youtube video
last but not least let's do up
austin kelly a fairly new patron who
i've been getting to know recently this
guy
is already on a faster track to not only
becoming super famous
um being sexy in the music business but
also
kicking everyone's ass along the way
martial arts expert musician he recently
got hooked up with something pretty cool
where he could start doing some
recording for his music
oh big comics aficionado this guy is
very smart
very skilled physically in every
department i mean he seems like he's the
whole package
so austin kelly when you come to
california
don't ever come around me because i'm
going to
my my ego will just go way way down
and i'm going to feel less than if i'm
around you i appreciate you being a part
of our patreon page
i'm so happy for all the success and
progress you've been making if you're
around me
my confidence is just gonna go flying
out the window
and uh you don't want to see that you
don't want to see what it looks like
because then i take it out
on all those who are in very vulnerable
positions
a lot of death flicker so
you'd be a hero by not being around me
i'm just kidding love to meet you buddy